>> Alright, so we have our code. We have our editor. Let's open up the code
in the editor. We can just pull this
over from Finder and have this nice little sidebar.
>> That is cool. I had no idea you could do that. Okay, so these
are all our files. This is looking
familiar now. I played around with these before.
>> Okay.
>> So this, these are all JavaScript files.
I don't want to look at them right now.
>> Alright. The one that seemed most important was the index file.
>> Mm-hm, yeah. So this is the
HTML that we saw in the browser earlier.
>> Yeah. And so, so right, this is the HTML.
This is that great container with the rows and the cells.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I had some different tiles. I made a Udacity flavored version of this app.
>> Okay. I want to get them in there. So, basically,
I want these different, the two tile, the four tile-
>> Mm-hm.
>> To be something different.
>> Okay, so just replace the pictures.
>> Yeah, should we do that in here or is that going to happen in the CSS?
>> Well, let's see. Do we see anything in here about the pictures themselves?
>> I don't know.
>> Alright, so let's try looking.
>> So, you open up Style.
>> Yeah, so we've got a couple of different CSS.
>> So, the one we were playing with before
was the main, so maybe that's the place to go.
>> Yeah, that's probably, probably the best place to look.
>> Okay, so I'm going to search around for tiles and make some changes?
>> Alright.
>> Cool.